natasha and i have known each other
since we worked together as kids i love
her and it turns out we both love
something in common
the crossword puzzle crossword puzzle
and so we're going to play a game and
we're about to team up to solve a movie
theme crossword puzzle um and it's time
for light camera crossword
[Music]
all right here to read us the clues our
very own russ matthews that's right i'm
here i take this very seriously now here
are the rules you ladies have one minute
and one minute only on the clock to
solve seven movie theme
clues yeah thinking it's slow it should
be like 17 minutes oh my god later your
time but if you get stumped i will
reveal a letter in the word so just keep
guessing until you get it because
there's no passing all right like no
bounce like wheels not even a crosstalk
a fortune okay it's crosswords this just
became harrowing but let's do it yeah
this is not crossword this is ross word
and there are rules around here but we
also have prizes because natasha i know
you're an avid ice cream fan yes that's
one of my major things all right so if
you get all seven correct in one minute
you and our entire studio audience is
gonna go home with a prize a 150 gift
card to low calorie ice cream from nyx
hey
[Music]
i didn't know there was such a thing
calorie ice cream all right so ice cream
is on the line for the entire audience
let's get started let's give them what
they want time is on the clock right
here here is your first one it's two
across this fluffy s'more ingredient got
busted by dan acquaintance in 1984. stay
puft marshmallow man
marshmallow we'll take marshmallows i
said marshmallow i will accept it all
right
now here's five down
the clue is a type of fiction also the
lumpy stuff in orange juice pulp
pulp is the correct answer four across
the most seductive american pie flavor
according to jim
apple yeah the apple is correct
six down number of states and lucy's
first dates
huh i don't get the question fifty fifty
fifty fifty
by the way that lucy i was thinking
lucille ball sub seven across sir name
of actor who famously ad-libbed here's
johnny
three o'clock 10 seconds left it's what
made gretchen weiner's hair so big in
mean girls
i don't know a moose a gel first letter
is s
secrets
the answer is secrets all right
thank you
thank you
oh you missed we didn't get to because
you ran out of time one down the clue is
you might find meg ryan and tom hanks at
the top of this
which building have been the correct
answer but you only got six out of seven
right
but
guess what you still won because
everyone is going home
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen natasha
you can catch natasha in the new season
of russian doll streaming on netflix one
of the greatest shows
[Music]